je vous montre aujourd'hui un smartphone
qui ne sortira pas en france mais un
smartphone super intéressant pourquoi et
bien parce qu'il permet d'entrapercevoir
là où on peut aller surtout montré le
plus haut de gamme de ce que peut faire
xiaomi aujourd'hui en 2022 ce smartphone
c'est ça en tout cas la boîte est là le
smartphone est là c'est regarder ces
crises y glisse jean noir c'est le chai
au 1012 s ultra co développé en
partenariat avec l'oeil car
souvenez-vous les cales partenariat
c'était huawei qu'il avait aujourd'hui
c'est xiaomi qu'il allait de balmont
strictement rien à voir ensemble ça il
faut le savoir et xiaomi s'est dit tiens
si on veut un smartphone dingo un
smartphone avec une optique de fou avec
un capteur complètement hallucinant et
on va le vendre uniquement en chine pour
l'instant je pense qu'il continuera à
rester en chine mais si on regarde de
plus près et si on se projette un peu
c'est potentiellement ce qui pourrait
arriver en 2023 avec le chiot mis 13
cents valoir c'est parti on y va
regardez-moi ça alors c'est simple c'est
efficace une jolie boîte c'est un
smartphone qui je vous dis une fois de
plus et destinée au marché chinois dont
qu'il arrivera jamais chez nous
néanmoins si vous êtes curieux de marque
si vous êtes passionné par la tex un
truc qui pourrait vous tentez première
chose qu'on va bien voir c'est ce bloc
de charges pour voit que c'est pas fait
pour chez nous ça c'est un bloc de
charges chinois 67 watney donc de la
recharge rapide mais pour autant c'est
pas la charge la plus rapide qu'on
puisse avoir fait chier on y pense que
si vous connaissez la marque on sait que
sur nous a déjà montré des blocs de
charges vont aller jusqu'à 120 watts
alors est-ce qu'ils vont continuer aller
là dedans peut-être peut-être pas de
voir arriver d'ici quelques temps un
nouveau chiot mis douze communes avaient
l'habitude de voir les années
précédentes donc on se demande ce qu'ils
vont garder la charge 120 watts ou alors
est-ce qu'ils vont complètement changer
on voit là un bon pour la boîte mois
maintenant ce qui m'intéresse c'est ça
regardez moi ce smartphone regardez moi
ce blog photos il est massif il est
énorme et ça c'est vachement intéressant
parce que ils nous ont fait un truc de
dingue parce qu'ils ont intégré un
capteur de 1 pouces un capteur est
énorme et c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir des capteurs aussi
grand dans des smartphones pour autant
on l'a déjà vu de très beaux capteurs
pour autant on a plein de très jolies
photos fans mais des capteurs de 1
pouces pas des masses alors là ils ont
fait vraiment le choix de mettre en
place enfin j'veux dire on y est là
clairement pourrait presque faire un
deuil à côté comme ça si on voulait
qu'ils ont fait ce choix nous dit
regardez ça c'est massif on assume c'est
la photo et on vous le marquis si les
cas le partenariat il fermés noir sur
blanc lorsque j'ai ouvert j'ai trouvé
que ce smartphone j'ai trouvé un petit
peu lourd et assez déséquilibré parce
que on a vraiment le poids à l'avant qui
situe au niveau du module photo encore
ce que vous tenez comme ça dit roy c'est
lourd par ici la voyez c'est quand même
une petite belle bête elle fait 225
grammes tout le cadre est en aluminium
ce qu'on retrouve aujourd'hui sur les
smartphones un petit peu classiquement
et l2 on met un dos en cuir vegan le
curé gagnent ça n'existe pas c'est une
matière plastique sauf que comme il nous
faut un petit imprimé il faut qu'ils
aient un petit côté cuir à peu près lui
offre de reconnaître surtout qui est
très sympa mais du curve égal talent
existe par ces sois du cuir car ça n'est
pas du tout vegan c'est de la baisse est
de l'animal soit c'est une matière
synthétique est ici c'est le cas avec un
petit imprimés alors j'aime bien les
finitions très simple en connaît là on
va retrouver à plein la grèce est écrit
noir sur blanc harman kardon by harman
kardon donc le son histoire partenariat
avec harman kardon on doit ici le petit
infrarouge d'un haut parleur son côté
sur cette tranche là je voulais montrer
le bouton pour ne l'allumé l'éteindre et
également le bouton de volume de l'autre
côté le tireur de cartes sim haut
parleurs également d'un côté absolument
rien là vous avez un grand écran c'est
du 6,73 pouces c'est une dalle ltp au de
deuxième génération ltps nous permet
d'avoir un taux de rafraîchissement
variable et ici on en rafraîchissement
variable qui va entre 1ère ce pour le
all ways and display lorsque je vient
appuyer comme ça voyez je suis sûre du
1er souk et ça marche très très bien et
ensuite je vais arriver jusqu'à 120
hertz son maximum pour avoir le maximum
de fluidité nombre une dalle qui est
très très bien maîtrisé c'est une dalle
amoled on est sur du quad hd + 3200 par
mille 400 pixels ratio vingt neuvième
alors une dalle micro incurvé si vous
regardez bien sur les côtés on voit
qu'elle est légèrement incurvé il ya des
gens qui aimeront d'autres qui
n'aimeront pas du tout les dalles
incurvé où je trouve assez sympa c'est
dans un peu plus de profondeur à l'image
trouve un peu plus d'immersion c'est une
dalle 10 bits on est une colorimétrie
dci p3 on va jusqu'à 1500 dit beaucoup
de luminosité et on a un écran qui
certifiait lutter contre la lumière
bleue autant vous dire qu'ici en deuil
dalle qui est vraiment très très belle
signé shiomi autre truc à venir
connaître comme ils sont dit tiens on va
faire un smartphone avec le maximum de
performance en photo on va également à
l'événement au niveau de la performance
globale du smartphone on a un seul un
dragon 8 + diane wood qui est très
performant gravé par tsmc donc on va
venir éviter ici les problèmes de
chauffe qu'on avait avec le 8 jonone on
a soit 8 soit 12 il peut déduire 50 ans
vous dire que sa partie d'un axe et on a
soit 256 72 giga de stockage en nuage
fasse 30 - 1 la batterie aussi très
grosse m'attendre à un peu plus grand
mais ça conviendra
4860 on est de la recharge voulait
montrer ici c'est du 60 7 watts on a dû
50 watts sans fil et on a également la
charge au regard s'est dit what voulait
venir à charge et une montre des voeux
des compagnies très facilement ici
l'expérience logiciel je vous la passe
très rapidement on est sûr me why 13
basé sur android 12 comme on est sur un
smartphone version chinoise j'ai des
applications chinoise je n'ai pas de
service google donc je n'ai pas de
youtube je n'ai pas tout ça alors je
peux venir les récupérer et les voir
directement ici dans mon navigateur mais
voyez c'est du chinois doute écrit en
chinois donc bon voilà il faut savoir le
je ne sais pas lire le chinois je ne
sais pas si c'est votre cas peut-être
d'ailleurs dès que moi on va dans les
commentaires bon on va pas aller
extrêmement loin au niveau d'expérience
logiciel est gelée soit effectivement en
mandat soit en anglais je suis en
anglais c'est quand même beaucoup plus
pratique mais moi le sujet qui
m'intéresse si tout cela est derrière au
niveau de la photo alors si vous
regardez bien vous avez au centre un
capteur principal cinq capteurs de 50
méga pixels qui co développé en
partenariat avec sony en tout cas chez
oh oui nous dit l'avoir cofinancer c'est
la somme i mx 989 capteur de 1 pouce et
fiorino dix en utilisent l'intégralité
du capteur de 1 pouce pour avoir une
qualité maximale au niveau de votre
photo on a bien évidemment stabilisation
optique mais vous avez également ici la
regarder juste là un ultra grand angle
capteur de 48 mégapixels on ouvre à f
2.2 et vous avez juste en bas ici un
zoom périscopique qui nous permet
d'avoir un tel objectif 4 x 5 en optique
bien sans oublier une caméra 3d tough
qui permettra à faire pas mal de choses
pour la photo de nuit pour le mode
portrait tout en sachant que à l'avant
vous avez également ici une petite
caméra qui planque et là c'est une 32e
mégapixels alors voilà pour la fiche
technique se trouve extrêmement robuste
maintenant regardons ce que ça dit au
niveau de la photo alors ok ok ok on
pourrait dire que je triche je vous
montre le stock le plus beau le plus
dingue c'est un sport que j'adore c'est
le puits devis chatel à côté de clermont
ferrand on est dans la chaîne des puys
des volcans c'est juste magnifique
allons regarder si vous montrer tout ça
là on est effectivement sur ce capteur
de 1 pouces une technologie font du
pixel bunning c'est à dire qu'ils vont
récupérer 4 pixels pour faire un seul et
même groupe xl pour avoir plus de
détails pour venir améliorer les photos
y avoir un rendu complètement maximisée
amenez moi je trouve que les photos sont
vraiment très jolie alors après on
pourrait venir dire halte et la
colorimétrie ge pourrait l'avoir comme
ci comme ça franchement je trouve que le
rendu est très très jolie là on est sur
un ultra grand angle regardez-la l'herbe
elle est très naturel sans lui très
grand-angle je trouve que c'est tout de
suite un petit peu trop saturé ils vont
un peu trop loin c'est un peu moins
efficace là c'est sobre c'est simple
c'est beau et on va le voir tout le
temps regardez là c'est pareil ça c'est
le capteur de 1 pouces également ici
tout ça vraiment très très très jolie là
on passe sur l'ultra grand angle est
quand même une vraie différence au
niveau de la colorimétrie pareil là
capteur de 1 pouces on voit quand même
des choses au centre alors ce que j'aime
bien et c'est ça que ils vont pas se
dire ok on va venir pousser trop les
zones d'ombré que ce soit un petit peu
plat on garde quand même ce côté un
petit peu très foncé au niveau de
l'ombre mais pour autant on y voit bien
là c'est pareil au niveau des petits
diables sur le côté on voit bien ce qui
se passe je trouve ça plutôt bien fichu
il faut qu'il travaille très très bien
ici d'un point de vue rigaud donc ça
s'est assez bien fait l'âge venu avec le
zoom périscopique donc fatalement
fouassin comme on se rapproche eh bien
on récupère choses un peu plus clair là
là il a eu un peu plus de mal il m'a
cramé le barça c'est un peu la limite
ici d'une périscopique pareil capteur de
1 pouces sous que la photo est très
jolie il voyait dès qu'on passe sur
l'ultra grand temps que c'est un petit
peu différent après la très honnêtement
le spo tous je vous emmène il juste
incroyable à contre-jour ça marche
également savez la chaîne des puys
derrière un peu de tourisme en même
temps qu'un des leurs aux vins se
rapproche un peu l'ultra grand angle
gardez là ce que c'est pas la classe
quand même avec un lac juste là et hop
zoom périscopique franchement ça marche
on va se rapprocher du cratère du volcan
on descend donc là vous avez le cratère
du volcan toujours pris en photo avec ce
capteur de 1 pouces ultra grand angle un
peu moins bien hélas ce que j'aime bien
c'est voyez je me suis pris en photo
alors je tenais le smartphone un bout de
bras en fait j'avais le smartphone comme
ça voyez je me prenaient en photo moi
directement et c'est là où on voit que
ça marche vachement bien ce capteur de 1
pouces c'est que je suis pas un mot de
portraits je suis en photos très
standard très classique je prends ta
guise a pu avec mon doigt et bien ça me
fait tout un flou en arrière plan ça ne
des tours très bien et je trouve que la
photo est juste superbe très très joli
jeu les continue et l'autre côté gilles
battier on va continuer on va voir un
peu ce que ça raconte est pareil ça
marche vraiment bien c'est net c'est
beau on a un côté un peu plus flous
d'arrière chou c'est vraiment vraiment
efficace et variés dès qu'on passe sur
la caméra de cellfish tout de suite
beaucoup plus terne il n'y a pas de
couleur regardez-la la couleur de
l'herbe regardez comme c'est saturé
c'est super joli les teintes de peau le
flou est sûre la caméra de celle fils
est terne c est un c'est moche ça ne
marche pas voyez c'est la caméra de
celle fit également caméras sa fille
c'est pas terrible c'est plat s'écraser
nous dirait qu'on a viré un peu la
saturation c'est pas terrible les décors
passe tout de suite sur le réacteur de 1
pouces ça marche beaucoup mieux et moi
vraiment ce que je préfère alors je vous
montre quelque temps la bouche du très
grand angle par un capteur d'un pouce
parce que je préfère vraiment je trouve
très très très fort le smartphone c'est
lorsque vous venez prendre en photo un
sujet directement avec le capteur de 1
pouces vous vous prenez vous directement
vous retournez le smartphone et là vous
avez une photo qui est vraiment belle
avec ce flou tout en sachant a une fois
de plus je lui dis je le redis que je ne
suis pas du tout en mode portrait donc
voyez je trouve que si omi a vraiment
bien bossé et a pris les choses au
sérieux alors bien évidemment ce
smartphone n'est pas totalement parfait
il ya des choses qui ne me conviennent
pas je vous dis la caméra de saïfi des
choses à dire corrigé d'un point de vue
purement algorithmique mais lorsque vous
le prenez à la main que vous shootez
vous le résultat est sans appel la photo
est super rebelle et c'est là où on voit
la force là où ils veulent aller alors
bien évidemment on peut faire plein de
choses on peut faire de la vidéo essayer
ça mais comme c'est pas un smartphone
qui va sortir je vais pas vous donner
envie vous frustré donc on va pas aller
jusqu'au bout du bout du bout mais voyez
vous avez un mode pro vous avez le mode
vidéo le mode photo le mode portrait
bien évidemment un choc d'une fois plus
gelé page twitter parce que tout à
l'heure j'étais vraiment en mode photo
classique bonne nuit et puis j'ai plein
d'autres choses les modes blog les cils
et ça le mode super lune bref donc ce
que je trouve vachement intéressant
c'est de vous montrer ce qu'ils vont
faire en fait parce que vous aligner
deux choses vous aligner un capteur de 1
pouces qu'ils ont co développé avec sony
vous mettez pas devant une lentille
laïka ce qui fait que vous venez
vraiment aligner les planètes vous avez
un smartphone avec un très bon
processeur qui calcule super bien vous
avez derrière tout ce qui va bien au
niveau hardware et après ils n'ont plus
qu'à travailler et appliqué le software
pour maximiser totalement rendus au
niveau des photos est ce que je trouve
génial est super intéressant aussi c'est
que effectivement même si ce smartphone
je ne vous conseille pas de l'acheter nu
en impôts renie rien parce que vous
gagneriez avec la garantie ça serait pas
géré par la france serait au global donc
il faudrait renvoyer s'il y avait un
problème en plus vous n'aurez pas les
services google ne seront pas installés
dans si la galère également vous serez
en chinois donc vraiment je ne vous
recommande pas de venir arracher ce
smartphone par contre ce que ça montre
c'est peut-être là où on va aller avec
le chien ont mis treize années
prochaines est-ce qu'ils vont venir nous
mettre un truc aussi performant est ce
que on va
voir un capteur de 1 pouce sur le che au
1013 ultra peut-être allez savoir
peut-être même avant peut-être d'ici la
fin de l'année donc ça on regardera
ensemble donc venez vous abonner dès
maintenant si ce n'est pas déjà fait
puis si vous êtes abonné mais actionner
la cloche pour être notifié dès qu une
prochaine vidéo arrivera dans ses
smartphones je trouve cool après il ya
tout ce qu'il faut à l'intérieur on a du
bluetooth 5.2 on a dû à 9,6 pour les
paiements dématérialisés
il est certifié ip 68 du wifi si ce bref
on à la complète il est très complet il
est beau il est bien vous avez quatre
haut parleurs bref il est très cool une
fois de plus il montre là où on va aller
l'année prochaine si schumi ne sort pas
en europe et dans le reste du monde il
ya une raison il est réservé uniquement
au marché chinois peut-être que ça a
marché qui est plus actif que le marché
que nous on va voir ici en europe et en
france en tout cas on commence à voir
les eaux annonce n ya pas très longtemps
le partenariat avec leica donc pour moi
c'est le premier smartphone de shiori
convoi arrivé ici avec les cas et s'il
vous met à capteur de 1 pouces avec ses
pas pour rien c'est pour dire attention
on est là on y va extrêmement fort on a
les cas on un capteur de 1 pouces qu'on
a co développé avec sony les concurrents
accrochez-vous et romaine dans votre
slip parce que franchement ça va
déboîtée et je trouve ça très
intéressant alors ce smartphone en chine
il faudrait l'équivalent en france 2000
euros il est évident que s'il arrivait
en france avec les différentes taxes du
coup très bien plus de 1000 euros je
suis en vie c'est très bien qu'ils
vendront pas des tonnes de smartphones
dans le haut de gamme mais en montrant
les muscles et s'ils continuent de
travailler leur crédibilité dans le
milieu de gamme et dans l'entrée de
gamme afin de renforcer la marque pour
se dire ok moi j'achète un smartphone de
xiaomi c'est une marque et sérieuse
regarde ce qu'ils font sur le haut de
gamme j'ai un smartphone peut-être
milieu de gamme peut-être d'entrée de
gamme mais c'est la marque qui est un
capteur de 1 pouces sony et c'est
également la marque qui a légué en
optique donc trouve ça assez
intéressante dites moi ce que vous en
pensez vous juste en bas en commentaire
comment vous le trouvez ce smartphone
est ce que vous pourriez aller au oui
non pas comment marquer moi tout ça qui
bien évidemment continuera par les
chiots me on en parlera d'ailleurs très
bientôt donc venez vous abonner s'est
pas déjà fait et puis surtout dites moi
ce que vous pensez de ce smartphone même
si bien évidemment vous ne ferez pas
plus en bras sur le fangu des bisous
ciao
[Musique]